when the second plane plowed through we
were
just a few stories below you're in this
concrete bunker of a fire stairwell
and it's shaking back and forth like you
can't believe in the
handrails breaking away from the wall
and the concrete spidering out and the
steps
like waves in the ocean undulating
underneath your feet
we were on the 105th floor of two world
trade center the south tower the
gentleman
from aon corporation came into the room
explained that there had been an
explosion that's what he called it an
explosion
in the north tower and that we had to
evacuate
my husband came running into the room
and shook me awake
and he was yelling and screaming and
saying a bomb went off
in the world trade center a bomb went
off you got to come see
that's the first chance we had to see
what was going on in the north tower
probably the worst 30 seconds of my life
furniture and paper and people
being pulled through those holes in the
building
and out against their will
i remember thinking that this that was
no accident
because that plane it tilted like this
and it was very clear that it was a very
deliberate
move and the the shock waves
from the impact of that plane going into
the building actually blew us
back into our apartment and knocked us
out it was just a few moments later
i was somewhere between 74 and 72
when the second plane plowed through our
building
so we were just a few stories below
the strike zone at that point you're in
this concrete bunker of a fire stairwell
and it's shaking back and forth like you
can't believe in the
hand rails breaking away from the wall
and the concrete spidering out and the
steps
like waves in the ocean undulating
underneath your feet
and that's the chance we had for the
first time to
encounter the police the firefighters
and the paramedics from new york city
going in the other direction um
just the looks in their eyes told
the story they knew
as we got into the south tower a woman
came to us
yelling and screaming there are people
trapped in the elevator
and they were screaming and yelling not
not just because they had just fallen
70 floors free fall 70 floors
but the elevator pit below them was on
fire with jet fuel
and they were right above it so they
were getting burned
and they were trapped i try not to think
about the choices that
i had up there there were over 200
people who jumped to their death
now i don't know if hagai was one of
those people or not like god tells me he
probably was
because that was something that he could
control well at least i'll have a body
to bury
you have this momentary feeling of
final ness okay like this is it
um then you have that secondary feeling
of
now i got to keep moving we have no clue
what's going on here let's keep going
the uniforms that were there were just
screaming at us run run run don't stop
don't stop and uh
we got across the street from the
building uh
in front of st paul's chapel and we look
back and you see
this unbelievable ticker tape of
concrete steel and bodies
right at that point was when we heard
what was that
clearly the the twisting steel the
crumbling concrete of what once
was the south tower the building that we
were in
the first building to go down it was
[Music]
unbelievable
[Applause]
you hear this and you knew what it was
and you hear
the cries of hundreds of thousands of
people on the streets of new york all
screaming the same blood-curdling scream
at the same time
it's what i hear first thing in the
morning and lasting at night virtually
every
day
tower 2 collapsed onto the marriott
hotel
and the marriott hotel collapsed around
us pitch black you couldn't breathe
the dust was so thick it was caked in my
ears and in my mouth
and i was trying to breathe and i was on
my hands and knees and i was crawling
back toward the door i had come in at
liberty street
but the building was collapsed and
it was just piles and piles of steel and
rubble and glass
i could not believe that for a second
that i was still alive
but i wanted to get out of there as fast
as i could
i wanted to save my own life so that i
could help others
and i came across a metal roll down gate
and i put my fingers under it to raise
the gate up
and i lifted it up an inch or two and
all these fingers came
from the other side of the gate
and together we lifted the metal gate up
and we escaped
uh and got out there were 54 people
in that meeting and seven of us survived
most of whom have yet to be ever
formally
identified
so when those twin towers came down they
actually registered on the richter scale
as an earthquake
everybody went crazy people were
throwing themselves into
the hudson river they were running into
each other and
knocking into things it was it was
insanity i just remember
looking at this chaotic scene thinking
i'm not sure we're going to survive this
i think this might be the end all the
way in northern manhattan we could see
the white plume of smoke
we turn on the radio in the car and i'll
never forget the reporter saying they're
gone
the buildings are gone
like when you think 911 a lot of people
think of the trauma of the airplanes
crashing
of the people that died i think of all
that but i also think of 9 11 and the
days
after and the coordinated efforts of
everyone
so many people think the firemen
policemen nurses but there was so much
more down there than that
[Music]
every day every hour down there
i got to see more more of the loss
of all the people that were there
i saw what we cannot recover
bodies only body parts
and then i knew at that moment why my
husband couldn't talk
it haunted him and it haunts me to this
day
because once i came back i couldn't
sleep somebody decided to
flip this piece of metal over
and when they flipped it over we
realized that it was an
airplane seat and the torso of
somebody's body was
um burnt onto the seat half the people
who died that day have never been
identified
have never been found right they were
they were pulverized
right to less than ash to to
to an extent where there wasn't even
enough dna to identify them
everybody knew there was something funky
about that dust
and debris that covered lower manhattan
everybody knew
that can't be right and there was talk
from
our windows environmental protection
agency that oh
we're monitoring and the air quality is
fine
and of course fast forward we find out
actually wasn't
good at all it's caused over 60
different forms of cancer
it had human remains in it you were
breathing in
electrical wiring and in
a massive amount of concrete and jet
fuel they say now
more people have died breathing in that
toxic air and what it did to your body
than people who died on the day of the
attack they identified 158 cancers
and our government will only recognize
56.
i mean it's just horrible that we've we
had to fight for our country 19 years
ago and now we're
fighting our own country just to be
recognized for
simple basic
[Music]
insurance my husband has um
bladder cancer um
i lost my kidney to cancer but
one of the illnesses that they're
looking at now is that
many of us who are down there
um we're showing early signs of dementia
and alzheimer's parkinson's and
we've had so many suicides in our
community
because they can't handle
they can't handle 911 they cannot handle
their illnesses anymore there's no help
out there
it's been 19 years since 9 11
and i'm very grateful for the 19 years
unfortunately now i do have cancer i
have a
lymphoma i do see myself as a victim of
for sure we all were we all were the
people
the people in the plains the people in
the towers the pentagon shanksville
the uh the residents and and and
denizens
of manhattan yeah we were victims we
were victims of terror
absolutely you know i didn't feel anger
or hatred after nine of them i didn't i
i was very sad but to me 9 11 was about
hatred
so to feel hate was like i'm no better
than they are
now i'm angry
you